[Música]
buenas tardes a todos bienvenidos a esta
entrevista de france 24
hoy estamos en zipaquirá en la catedral
de sal de zipaquirá donde nos recibe en
gran bernal el ciclista colombiano que
acabo de ganar el giro de italia dos
años después de su triunfo en el tour de
francia buenas tardes secan como esta
con emma buenas tardes muy bien gracias
mi primera pregunta es justamente sobre
su estado de salud de cómo se siente
porque acaba de tiene el cúbito justo
después de su victoria al giro se
contagió con cubrir y el retraso su
venida de columbia a causa del cobit
cómo se siente ahora un honor haber dado
muy bien
afortunadamente no seas tú el coach pero
nada nada del otro mundo no fue tan
grave así que nada en su momento en ese
momento bien estoy empezando a entrenar
y por el momento sin ningún problema
pero bueno igual hay que ir con
tranquilidad poco a poco y vamos a ver
cómo cómo responde el cuerpo en estos
próximos días esta victoria el giro de
italia que representa para usted que que
empezó su carrera profesional en italia
justamente se quedó dos años en italia y
ha dicho que era la carrera más
importante hasta más importante que el
tour para usted de poder ganar
para mí el libertario siempre ha sido
muy importante
como se lo decía vivían ya dos años
inicie
a correr a los 19 años con el equipo
androni así que estaba siempre he sido
muy muy allegado a ese país
así que obviamente el ganar esta carrera
es es algo es algo realmente realmente
especial para mí
fue fueron dos victorias muy diferentes
entre el tour de 2019 y el giro de 2020
como los in which qué tan diferente es
para usted porque podría decir no vengan
el tour girl you es más o menos igual y
dice que es totalmente diferente porque
son son dos carreras totalmente
distintas y la sensación que he tenido
en las dos carreras es es difícil de
comparar no podría comparar la una con
la otra
el estudio es el tour el tour ese
estudio
y le hagan a los 22 años y no esperaba
en ese año ganar el tour de francia
quería hacerlo bien sí pero pues no fui
como yo como ayudará a otro compañero en
esa carrera así que quería hacerlo bien
pero al mismo tiempo era consciente de
que si en algún momento tenía que
trabajar para otra persona pues no lo
iba a hacer
así eso significará puedes perder mis
opciones personales así que
el tour llegó y no me lo esperaba fue
como una sorpresa y fue como el primer
boom de gamonal el primer boom pues
grande realmente grande una gran vuelta
y luego después de esto pues después del
año tan complicado que tuve en el 2020
el giro de italia se convirtió como en
el regreso
para mí más que todo personalmente
quería como que ésta fuera la carrera de
otra vez estoy acá después de ese año es
tan complicado otra vez estoy acá
yo pude un poco como controlar todo ese
tipo de cosas que no me permitían estar
en un buen nivel y bueno acá estoy es
una especie de revancha
bueno si se podría se podría ver de esa
forma quería eso regresar y hacerlo bien
en la primera grande que fuera competir
obviamente podía pasar de todo estaba
preparado para todo está preparado para
obviamente o ganar o incluso no sé
retirarme así que bueno todo salió bien
menos mal pero pues iba a ser también un
es un poco un arma de doble filo
prepararlo y estar súper concentrado
para eso pero también era consciente de
que podía que todo saliera mal o otra
vez por la espalda
qué tan duro y que tanto le afectó el
año 2020 que vivimos
físicamente pero también mentalmente muy
tocado al momento de competir que qué le
pasó exactamente en 2020
en el momento de
del tour
fue más físicamente la verdad no era el
problema a la espalda que tuve que tenía
mucho dolor por culpa del escenario que
se está
tocando con un hueso era lo que generaba
el dolor y eso era lo que no me permitía
hacer esfuerzos
a alto nivel entonces básicamente eso
fue a nivel físico luego el tema mental
me note después de que cuando empiezo a
perder tiempo y el sentir que no iba a
poder de verdad estar a mi nivel como me
gustaría estar para lo que me había
preparado porque físicamente antes de
estos problemas estaban muy bien allí y
eso es algo que poca gente sabe ya que
yo acá antes de irme para ese tour se ha
estado haciendo mis mejores números está
rompiendo mis récords incluso estaba
subiendo más rápido que el año anterior
que había ganado el tour y verme allá en
estas carreras y no poder hacer la
potencia que quería o la potencia que yo
sé que hubiera podido hacer en ese
momento por el problema físico
y mentalmente fue complicado
y el después del tour pues pues el tener
que empezar toda esta preparación y de
verdad incluso estar unos días en la
casa en el que incluso estando acostado
me dolía la espalda fue complicado y por
eso mentalmente ff fue difícil en ese
momento
como un logro para recuperar su nivel y
volver ahí a la cima de su deporte bueno
con mucha con mucha paciencia y como
decimos nosotros hacer con un hombre
como berraquera
el hecho de de levantarse un día y decir
esto no me va a quedar grande ya no sé
si va a ganar o no pero quiero volver
una competencia y volver a estar en la
mejor versión de ella no sé si ganar o
no ganado porque finalmente eso se
convierte en algo secundario lo que
quería y lo que aún no yo creo como
deportista más le importa es estar en su
mejor versión y eso es lo que quería
entonces ya cuando era consciente de eso
de que era lo que quería
pero no fueron unos meses en los que día
a día trabajaba por ese objetivo y no se
me quitaba de la mente es lo que quería
así que yo creo que puedes o no
levantarse un día decir bueno listo de
ahora en adelante todo o nada hace ayer
que estamos en un contexto en colombia
muy difícil entre la pandemia entre una
crisis social desde finales de abril con
un paro nacional con con mucha mucha
violencia mucha violencia policial muy
autos
en este contexto como como siente el
país y la importancia de su victoria
para el país pero también cuál cuál es
su opinión sobre lo que está pasando en
su país
bueno eso es difícil
hablar en este momento d
de lo que está pasando en el país porque
acá nos quedaríamos todo el día hablando
hablando del tema es un tema muy
complicado qué
que no es fácil de tocar pero pues
obviamente todo lo que estamos viviendo
eso no lo digo un poco en mis redes
sociales
hace un tiempo antes de iniciar el libro
lo que pensaba dt del tema
pero la verdad el poder aportar de una
forma u otra a esta situación es poder
dar al menos un motivo de alegría al
país en este momento que tanto lo
necesita pues no sé para mí es motivo de
orgullo y me gustaría que esto sirviera
como de motivación a muchas personas que
están pasando en su momento situaciones
complicadas y que sea algo juego para
llenar de ilusión y que ya tenemos cosas
buenas y que nos recuerde lo buenos que
somos nosotros como colombianos eso yo
creo que es importante
estamos en un año olímpico y parece que
nos va a participar en los juegos
olímpicos porque si no lo hacemos
solamente no no voy a poder estar en los
olímpicos
porque ni siquiera estoy seguro si voy a
estar en un buen nivel en la vuelta
españa que es en dos meses y en los
olímpicos ya hacen nada
s nada de tiempo así que después de que
de que termine el tour de francia
entreno tres veces se montan bicicleta
tres veces dos con mi novio y uno con mi
mamá así que no he tenido mucho tiempo
para para prepararme tuve cosita así que
tuve que hacer la cuarentena y no he
tenido tiempo
así que
no voy a poder estar en un buen nivel en
los olímpicos y este punto prefiero que
vaya otra persona mi última pregunta es
sobre este objetivo de hacer la vuelta
para ir a ganarla ha dicho y sería el
hay muy pocos corredores que hicieron el
doble el doblete el mismo año
quiero digital ya vuelta hay solamente
tres y sería el más joven y si la gana
este año sería el corredor más joven de
la historia a ganar las tres grandes
vueltas usted busca marcar la historia
de su deporte
pues a mí me gustaría marcar la historia
del deporte pero pero
pero lo decía antes va a ser difícil
el estar en el nivel que se necesita
para ganar una gran vuelta este año en
la vuelta españa no he tenido tiempo de
entrenar porque claro el plan original
que teníamos después del libro italia
era descansar unos 10 días 7 10 días y
luego empezar a entrenar full para la
vuelta españa pero pues no pude porque
me dio hobby y entonces claro empecé a
entrenar ayer para para la vuelta españa
estuve mucho tiempo sin montar en
bicicleta y no sé si voy a poder estar
a mi nivel para esa carrera obviamente
me gustaría pero pues va a ser
complicada hay que ser también hay que
soñar pero en un tiempo a cierto punto
hay que ser realista con los objetivos
hay que encontrarse ese balance pero
pero en igual eso no quita el hecho de
que me vaya a preparar lo mejor posible
que bueno uno nunca sabe las vueltas que
da la vida tal vez llegue y se esté en
un buen nivel o uno uno no sabe pero
pues por el momento puede intentar hacer
las cosas lo mejor posible e intentar
estar allá lo mejor que pueda en este
momento hay muchísimas gracias muchas
gracias mucha suerte por lo que viene y
por la vuelta de españa y a ustedes
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros y
síguenos en tramos 24 y france 24 punto
com muchas gracias
[Música]